yeah so here at the Google i/o
conference right as 50 50 80 550 500
developers gathered to learn the very
latest of the google operating system
but this is a different kind of event
while it's being held at the moscone
center the same place where the the
first iTunes was announced the first
iphone was announced it's a very
different event that the kind of events
Apple would hold we're with bated breath
the fans of the company would gather
waiting to find out what the latest
thing is and what already knows what the
latest thing is they know about the
payment systems that Google has had
around for a while they know about the
general trends towards improved security
and speed that the new operating system
offers which are the same kind of things
the old operating system offered this
both we just a little bit better but
google announces things differently
google announces things iteratively over
time so their developers can continually
make improvements and so their hardware
partners of course it's an open
operating system so hardware partners
can plan and make decisions about what
they're going to make and when they're
going to make it and which pieces of
this operating system they want to use
now there are big splashes that happen
like the time that one of the Google
founders parachuted into the place while
wearing Google glass a product that had
already been largely announced they make
some noise with their self-driving cars
you might see some of that over the
course the next few days but
interestingly Google does things over
time not just in an event like this is
the importances of that maybe a little
less than a big apple announcement vikas
understand honestly what's the point of
it all what is the point of that event
the expense the pomp the circumstance
the parachuting the show what's real
point
yeah so I think if your developer it is
the biggest mobile operating system of
the world there are tens of thousands of
developers in the world who develop on
this platform and really need to learn
some of the latest little tricks and
techniques they want to make some
business deal so try to expand the
business is that they've built on top of
Android and so the opportunity to have
those meetings the opportunity to attend
sessions will they learn about new ways
to code on the platform those are
important for the companies running
running businesses here and that's kind
of the main focus here not big product
announcements put the minutiae of
building products on this platform